okay two of the dumbest tweets of the  week tulsi gabbard said this war and  suffering could have easily been avoided  if biden and nato simply acknowledged  russia's legitimate security concerns  regarding ukraine becoming a member of  nato which would mean u.s nato forces  right on russia's border  putin  chose to invade ukraine that's the first  analysis that we need tulsi's offer  rocker again  ben shapiro secularism must be imposed  from the top down religion must be built  from the ground up wrong if you look at  history very often it is religion which  is imposed from the top down and  resistance to that dissent from that  religion is actually what has to be  built from the ground up and sometimes  that includes secularism sometimes just  it's simply not the religion being  imposed on us ben and tulsi both very  very wrong